thank you very much and yes indeed the
history of jihad is the first book that
chronicles the entirety of the
phenomenon of jihad for 1400 years not
just the jihad against Europe although
that's very much a part of the book but
also the jihad against India and the
jihad elsewhere also tying in the fact
that the israeli-palestinian conflict is
itself a jihad and of course the people
who struck us at on 9/11 were motivated
by the exact same ideology that has
motivated the jihad conquests of the
distant past and is still with us very
much today and of course one of the
reasons why anybody is interested in
reading history or studying history is
because of the old adage those who do
not remember the past are condemned to
repeat it and more to the point really
is that if you do not learn from your
mistakes you keep making the same
mistakes again and again and again and
that's u.s. foreign policy today because
of in large part a lack of awareness and
understanding of the nature and
magnitude of the jihad threat and of a
complete lack of knowledge of the
history of jihad so I thought this
morning very briefly I'd give you three
lessons from history that could have a
very great impact on foreign policy
today in the United States were there to
be sanity in the State Department which
of course I know is at a premium now the
first one is that nowhere in history and
this is something to bear in mind when
you're thinking about the case of Jamal
khashoggi who is of course the sainted
and martyred journalist who was killed
by the Saudis he was actually a pro
al-qaida Muslim Brotherhood operative
who was killed by the Saudis
so there are no good guys in that story
but in light of it it is important to
remember that when you look through and
examine and study the history of Islam
for 1400 years there has never been a
lasting alliance between a Muslim state
and a non-muslim state it would be nice
if there had been there were some
short-term alliances of convenience but
that's another problem as well
for example John the sixth canto
Cousineau s' was a Byzantine Emperor in
the middle of the 14th century and there
was a claimant to the Byzantine Imperial
throne who disputed his claim so he
asked his pal the Ottoman Sultan to help
him by sending some armies into Europe
to fight against the rival claimant very
fruitful Alliance for John the sixth
can't accuse eNOS except that the
Ottomans entered Europe they have not
yet left the Turks still control the
area around what was known as the city
of Adrianople and that is their claim to
be part of the European Union which they
are still pushing and more to the point
the Ottomans never gave up trying to
destroy the Byzantine Empire even though
they had made various alliances with not
just John the sixth but other business
Emperor's the Byzantine emperors were
not thinking about the reality of the
jihad imperative that an Islamic state
that is a validly in Islamic state and
is dedicated to Islamic principles is
going to be aware of the Islamic
imperative to wage war against
unbelievers and to conquer and subjugate
them it may well make use of those
unbelievers at various points for its
own advantage but it will never be
friends with those unbelievers as a
matter of fact there's a famous passages
in the Quran that says do not take Jews
and Christians as your friends and this
has often been dismissed
by Islamic apologists who say that
doesn't mean that any individual Muslim
won't be your pal
that means that an Islamic state must
not ally with a non-muslim state well
okay that's a lesson in itself as well
and so when we consider Saudi Arabia
Saudi Arabia finds the United States
useful and the United States finds Saudi
Arabia useful president Trump may have
some very good reasons right now to
maintain the alliance with Saudi Arabia
because of his predecessors disastrous
policies that empowered and enabled and
strengthened the Islamic Republic of
Iran another lesson from history is that
Sunnis and Shia hate each other
they hate infidels more but they do hate
each other and have been waging jihad
against each other for 1400 years as
well as against infidels and so the
Saudis and the Iranians will never be
friends they will always be rivals and
they will always be at odds and so when
the Iran was so strengthened and it
began to use the billions that Obama's
showered upon it to finance Hezbollah
and Hamas and Islamic Jihad and even Al
Qaeda and the Taliban then the president
is right to try to keep the Saudis on
our side and make sure that they stand
as a bulwark against Iran otherwise
Iranian power could directly threaten
the survival of the free world the
Saudis however are not a benign thing
and I think that anybody who might have
been carried away and thought that
Mohammed bin Salman was a genuine
reformer ought to have been awakened by
the fact that not only was Khashoggi
killed but he's not the only journalist
who the Saudis have recently killed and
he is also a Mohammed bin Salman has
also imprisoned the activists who called
for women to be able to drive so you see
he allowed women to drive and then he
arrested everybody who wanted it now why
would he do that
you see it's crazy but he's not nuts
what he's doing is trying to present
Saudi Arabia as a more benign nation to
encourage foreign investment especially
when the long-term trends for oil prices
are going down then he can attract
business into Saudi Arabia but that
doesn't mean that he wants any
dissenters of any kind or any challenges
of any kind to the ruling to the rule of
the House of Saud and that brings me to
the second lesson from Islamic history
there has never been a western-style
secular republic that was based on
Islamic principles now that is very
carefully worded because Turkey of
course was a western-style secular
republic up until quite recently and you
might you might have thought it still
was but actually Recep Tayyip air21 the
president of Turkey has been very
systematically and persistently
dismantling Kemalist secularism and
restoring this turkey as a an Islamic
state and one of the ways he did that
was to decapitate the military which had
always been the guardians of Turkish
secularism not talking about learning
the lessons of history consider this
secularism was imposed upon Turkey it
was never a ground-up ground roots
movement talk about astroturfing it's an
excellent example of it what happened
was this Kemal atatürk after World War
one thought he was unique in the Islamic
world unique in Islamic history in
saying reason why our country is in the
dumpster right now is because of Islam
and so if we are going to prosper we
need to imitate the nations that have
prospered and that's the West so we're
going to limit the power of political
Islam and imitate the West this is the
only time this has happened in Islamic
history and he established secular
Turkey on that basis and what he did was
very popular at the time in
Constantinople and Ankara the two
largest cities in Turkey and not popular
at all in the countryside and there were
several times before air Dewan was
elected that other people who wanted to
restore Islamic law
were elected to positions of power in
Turkey and every time that happened the
military would topple them from power so
the military preserved Turkey as a
western-style secular Republic for the
large part of the 20th century then what
happened early in the 21st century there
was a very very very large indications
that there was going to be another
military coup in Turkey and Secretary of
State Condoleezza Rice warned the
Turkish military that the United States
was a guardian of democracy and would
not accept any military coup in Turkey
and because of that now Turkey has
become not an ally of the United States
but a rapidly re Aslam izing nation that
directly aided Isis you know John Kerry
went to Turkey a few years ago when he
was Secretary of State and he said could
you please stop buying Isis oil and they
refused and air dhawan is famous for
having allowed thousands of foreign
jihadists to cross through Turkey into
the Isis domains in Iraq and Syria and
he would say we're gonna they would say
you have to fight Isis you know you're
in you're in NATO you have to do
something about this and he would say ok
and bomb the Kurds he never fought Isis
because he wanted to co-opt their
Caliphate into his own restored
Caliphate but since in the State
Department they don't know what a
Caliphate is they don't know anything
about history and they don't know what
the what the pillars of Turkish
secularism were they set this up they
made this happen and that's what is a
classic example of not knowing the past
and thus repeating the same mistakes and
being condemned to repeat the same
misery all over again and the third
lesson from Islamic history is that
there's never been a shortage of
non-muslims who are willing to help the
jihad there have always been plenty of
them and it never works out for them you
take for example the conquest of Spain
all of us in the room here know probably
that
Spain was conquered by Islamic armies in
starting in the year 711 they had the
whole country conquered by 718 and they
ruled it ruled it for 700 years until
they themselves were this this is one of
the only times this has happened in
history pushed out of Spain and by 1492
Spain was an entirely Christian nation
as it had been before the conquest but
fewer people know how the conquest came
about and what happened was there was a
Christian leader count Julian of seiyu
deseo de is in what is now Morocco and
it's still a Spanish possession many of
you are no doubt aware that sayyou de
and Mille Miglia are two enclaves that
are in Morocco in North Africa but
they're part of Spain and right now
they're being overrun by migrants from
Africa who go and climb the fence in
Sayeda and then they're in Europe even
though they're not they're in North
Africa they're in Spain and so they are
entitled to all the guarantees of
protection that the European Union is
giving to the migrants but count Julian
of seiyu de long ago he sent his
daughter to the court of King Roderick
the Visigothic king of Spain in order to
have her educated but King Roderick the
Visigoths the king of Spain treated in
turns rather like Bill Clinton did and
so
King count Julian was enraged and
appalled when he heard what had happened
and so he went to his friend Tara Kevin
Zia
who was the leader of the local the the
Muslim region of Morocco right next to
say OODA and he said I'll help you get
across the Strait because this is what
it's dimy to the Muslims they had boats
but every time they set sail across the
Strait of Gibraltar then they would find
that the Spanish would put their
defenses up because they would see them
coming they weren't moving all that fast
in those days so the count Julian gave
them his boats so that when the Spanish
who were manning the defenses saw them
coming they thought oh that's our friend
count Julian and they did not put up
their defenses or have the army ready so
Tara Cuban Zia got to Spain and he got
to he decamped his army and then he had
ordered the boats burned which I think
was rather ungracious of him since they
were a loner but what he was saying was
we're here to stay
we're gonna stay here we're gonna
conquer this place or we're gonna die
here but we're not going back and he
conquered Spain courtesy of count Julian
interestingly enough a few years back
there was a big controversy some of you
may recall in Minneapolis about a
charter school a public school that got
public funds that was essentially a
madrasah an Islamic school it got public
funds and was a public school but they
had Quran study they had prayers in
during school time and so on and people
got wind of this there was a controversy
ultimately the school was shut down
although it started right back up again
but that's another story the controversy
was raging all this time I was puzzled
because nobody ever in any of the
coverage that I ever saw about the
controversy nobody ever stopped to ask
wait a minute who is this tarek eben xia
that the school is named for why is it
called Tara cube and Z at academy Tara
cube and Ziad remember with the Spanish
conquered the Muslim conquer of Spain
who burns the boats probably anybody in
Minneapolis whoever gave it a moment's
thought
thought that he was some Muslim John
Dewey or something some sort of great
educator but in reality he was the great
conqueror of Spain the guy who burns the
boats and said we're here to conquer or
die now why do you think a school a
Muslim school in Minneapolis would call
itself terror given Z at academy what
could be the lesson there what do you
think they were trying to say but of
course nobody knows who terror given Z
ed was and so nobody thought to ponder
the significance of the name now in any
case count Julian was by no means alone
in his sponsorship of the Islamic Jihad
and his aid for its advance there have
been numerous non-muslims who have been
similarly helpful to the jihad cause
throughout history another primary
example came in Arabia at the end of the
18th century and in along into the
middle of the 19th and at that time
Arabia was nominally under the control
of the Ottoman Empire but there came to
be a revivalist movement in Arabia at
that time and there was a gentleman who
claimed to be the great Muslim reformer
a lot of people say we have to put our
hopes on Islamic reform and we can hope
that Islamic reform will happen and then
all our troubles will be over well I got
news for you Islamic reform has already
happened
and it happened it started in the middle
part of the 18th century in Arabia this
guy said the Ottomans had added all
these things into Islam he was going to
strip them out and get back to the
basics and he personally stoned an
adulteress to death and showed how eager
he was in doing so to enforce Islamic
law he got a wide following because he
did that he gained the aid of a local
chieftain in Arabia and they began to
make war against the Ottomans and the
other Arab chieftains in the area and in
the middle of the 19th century this
man's movement it became known as the
wahhabi movement because his name was
Muhammad ibn Abdullah ha
and the chieftain who helped him was
even Saud who of course later became the
founder he's later became recognized as
the founder of the Saudi clan which
today rules Saudi Arabia but they were
just one of a number of rival Arab
chieftains at the time and Muslim
preachers who were vying for control of
Arabia and all fighting the Ottomans but
they got noticed by the British and the
British thought hey we want to fight the
Ottomans
we can use these guys and it seems like
a good idea right because the Ottoman
Empire is the global Caliphate which is
the foremost exponent of offensive and
aggressive jihad so the British started
paying money to the Wahabis in the
middle of the 19th century and they
sponsored the Saudis to create Saudi
Arabia after World War one and they
actually decided who was going to be in
power in Arabia and gave Jordan to the
loser the Hashemite Kingdom of Jordan
the Hashemites are not from that area
there are Arabs there Arabians but they
lost the struggle with the Saudis and so
they got Jordan as a consolation prize
the Saudis meanwhile struck oil in 1938
and they used their billions to finance
this veralyn and violent understanding
of Islam that Wahab had originated they
spread it all around the world in areas
where the cultural form of Islam had
become a little bit more benign and so
it's really courtesy the British that we
have the revival of global jihad and the
creation of jihad terrorist groups in
the middle of the 20th century because
had it not been for the British the
Saudis would never have been much of
anything and then they would never have
been the beneficiaries of the oil strike
and never would have been able to
finance the global jihad today and so I
think we we we owe the British
government a great debt of gratitude for
that in any case I hope that this has
briefly made it clear why it's so
important to understand
history and particularly this very very
untraveled bit of history the history of
jihad which i think is one of the most
crucial stories of all human history and
one of the least known and so this is
one of the reasons why I wrote the book
I'm hoping that there will be a genuine
change in the public discussion as a
result of some of the things that are
made clear in the book that will in turn
themselves make clear that a great deal
of our foreign also domestic policy is
based on false assumptions wrong
assumptions wishful thinking and
outright fantasy thank you very much
[Music]
one question one question hi thank you
for being here I'm currently at
University and professors all love to
talk about the Islamic Golden Age and
how it was rational and they saved the
Renaissance and all these types of
things were those people adhering to
Islamic belief were they ignoring it or
am I being lied to as a student yes yes
and yes
the the fact is that the Islamic Golden
Age was in its part real and part
fiction there were great Islamic empires
and there were Islamic philosophers and
there was a time when there was peace
between Jews Christians and Muslims
particularly in Spain however the time
that there was peace between Jews
Christians and Muslims in Spain was only
when the Jews and Christians knew their
place accepted their second-class status
submitted to the hegemony of the Muslims
when as a matter of fact in the year
1066 the local Muslim leader in granada
appointed a jew as the vizier of the
city now this was because he knew this
guy and they were friends and you know
human nature is everywhere the same
sometimes people ignore laws but the law
is that a non-muslim must not have
authority over a Muslim and so the
people were incited and I described this
in the book the people were incited by a
poet who wrote a poem about how terrible
it was that the Jews were ruling over
them and they were incited to riot it
was a terrible pogrom and 4,000 people
were murdered and this was because the
people knew that a Jew must not hold
authority over a Muslim that was
wonderful tolerant Muslim Spain and
that's just one example of many that I
could give you the inventions the great
innovations a lot of that is just sheer
nonsense and it also begs the further
question when people talk about all the
wonderful things like I hear that a
hundred years before Copernicus some
Muslim astrology astronomer discovered
the same thing that Copernicus did that
the Sun doesn't revolve around the earth
and then you just gotta wonder well okay
well that led to a great deal of
innovation and further discovery in
Europe why did what happened in the
Islamic world and the great Islamic
philosophers they did influence Aquinas
and they had a great deal to do with the
Enlightenment in the Renaissance in
Europe but in Islam you only know of era
was an Avicenna and a few others because
after that they were declared heretical
and there was the al-ghazali himself a
great philosopher wrote the incoherence
of the Philosopher's saying that the
Philosopher's contradicted the Quran and
must be killed
that was a bit of a chilling effect on
Islamic philosophy and so what you have
also is the nowadays because there's
such an apologetic effort to sell Islam
to the West you have a lot of people
saying the the first hospital was in
Baghdad and under the the the Umayyad
caliphate well in the first place the
first hospital was many years before
that but in reality the hospital in
baghdad was run by christians and jews
who were under islamic rule so that's
not really something that's to the
credit of islam and on and on and on
nowadays there is a tremendous public
relations effort to rewrite history to
manipulate people into thinking I mean
for example Akbar Aqaba Akbar Ahmed is a
professor at American University and
he's written a book called journey into
Europe that he actually recommends a new
Andaluz for Europe which is essentially
saying he wants Europe to be conquered
by Islam and he presents that is this
wonderful Golden Age that your
professors tell you about but in reality
all Andaluz was no where any of us would
want to live and if we did we would
suffer to a great degree
so knowing history is good it's being
used as a weapon today to manipulate you
to accept public policies of nowadays
and so it's very important to be
informed thanks very much